would you tell us a little bit about
some of the sets like how how large was
a compound for example my wife and I
actually toured the floor one day and
you go in and it's really draw dropping
to look at these miniature sets and the
level of detail and then there's poles
everywhere holding the you know the the
uh the characters in place if you're a
fan of artman one of the things that you
love is you go through the film and
you're always going to see thumb prints
and fingerprints on character's necks
and I just love the lowte I love the
fact that you feel the human touch
literally on these films in fact CG's
gotten so good today that they could go
in and fake putting those in if they
want but they they don't do that
actually